active en janvier
nous sommes sur l'île miscou le point le
plus à l'aise du groupe de jouets sont
forts c'est historique construit il ya
164 et maintenant le témoin d'une pêche
portier de plus en plus populaire le bar
rayé les vagues battage le soleil en au
paradis notre guide et andré fortin des
choix gars enseignant de profession il
fera découvrir aux touristes depuis
quatre ans cette tâche parfois méconnus
du grand public
le premier client officiel c'est un ex
joueur de la ligue nationale
philippe poidevin que vraiment apprécié
la région aussi pour la vie chère sont
avec la nature la mer et tout ça j'ai
l'air des paris à ses côtés lui l'expert
mais il me rassure c'est une pêche qui
est accessible vraiment pour toutes les
catégories de gens donc c'est une pêche
qui est assez facile d'accès avec les
plages au niveau bronze jouer l'année où
exactement ce qu au confluent de la
sortie de la baie des chaleurs puis à
l'entrée du golfe saint laurent
ici tu as du gros courant qui se
rencontrent enfin normalement il ya
beaucoup de marins on a trouvé le bon
endroit
les fortes vagues et le temps brumeux ne
nuisent en rien il y a plusieurs façon
de pêcher le bar rayé pour commencer
avec ces conditions houleuses le leur au
caoutchouc
faisons d'abord un ans à 12 ans
avant d'aller sous le roulant de la bad
le tueur amène une bonne vitesse il bar
rayé peu après besoin ça y est ça andré
me fait une démonstration s'avançant
contre les vagues qui sont parfois
puissantes
car ici on pêche dans l'eau c'est ce
qu'on appelle du surf casting parce que
le surf en danger qu'ils le disent une
bague qui roulent en lance dans la vague
qu'on essaie de capturer du bar rayé des
foyers un danger en danger de se faire
avancer la vague dans le visage et je
vous jure ce n'est pas une histoire de
pêche au premier lancer une première
prise
on le mesure car on peut garder
seulement les poissons de 50 à 65 cm
puis un autre fait le minimum c'est un
coup dur de d'études dans la dea dans le
bar et y est un prédateur qui nuirait
aux autres activités de pêche un poisson
mal aimés on adage rata pas attraper des
bons rayé avec un moment dans la bouche
d'une patiente est un prédateur d'un
prédateur
sa moto devait lancer mon 4e essai sa
mort déjà la chance du débutant diront
certains une belle prise et on ne
travaillait pas pour le ramener 100%
c'est un sport la page pourquoi pourquoi
ben tu as toujours des défis tulle avec
aujourd'hui les lancers les techniques
on a fait une marche bon d'accord
rentrer dans l'eau à esquiver les vagues
andré forte et espère attirer plus d des
loisirs qui permet l'évasion pendant
quelques heures et avec une récompense
au bout de la ligne ont la réputation
d'être un poisson de 8h - mais on
l'assaisonné comme il faut et super
banque des chars blanche quand les
programmes du poulet avec ses conseils
c'est le retour à la maison avec l'eau à
la bouche et la tête remplie d'histoires
de pêche ici françois leblanc radio
canada sur l'île miscou